I have a tendency to overshare when I
first meet people so in keeping with
that habit I wanted to share that I'm a
medical
audity I'm a doctor who specializes in
Saving
Forest my Journey's been unusual and
through it I've learned how vital
tropical forests are for our
health as soon as I finished my internal
medicine training I traded in my scrubs
for a hmat suit I joined the epidemic
intelligence service at the Centers for
Disease Control and
prevention and for 9 years I was a
disease detective I chased outbreaks
around the world I Trek Through the
Jungle to research a bat hunting
Festival I even vaccinated raccoons from
an airplane on most days it was my dream
job but there were others when what I
saw was a
nightmare like when I went to West and
central Africa to help fight the two
biggest Ebola epidemics ever I came back
from both of those deployments with the
same feeling that our reactive approach
to Public Health is inherently
flawed we focus on preparing for
outbreaks so that we can respond quickly
but it's rarely that easy maybe a virus
like the one that causes covid spreads
between people before they know they're
sick maybe people choose to not take a
safe and effective
vaccine and before we know it the
outbreak grows into an epidemic or even
pandemic in other words we act as if
outbreaks are
inevitable if you ask me this is medical
negligence preparing and responding are
critical no doubt but alone they're not
enough this begs the question what if we
could also prevent outbreaks before they
even
begin well there's good news we can and
how we do so may surprise
you some researchers believe the West
African Ebola epidemic began within
ax communities in rural Guinea for their
survival had no choice but to clear
forest for
Farms then in 2013 in 18mth old boy died
of
Ebola he is believed to have caught the
virus from bats that lived in a hollow
tree where he played put in another way
the virus likely spilled over from bats
into this boy making him Patient Zero
from there Ebola spread killing more
than 11,000 people in West Africa ebola
animal Origins however aren't unique all
five viral pandemics from 1918 through
2009 can be traced to animals and the
same is likely true for covid perhaps
most concerningly the estimated number
of undiscovered viruses circulating in
animals that could potentially spill
over is over
600,000 spillover is also becoming more
common because of what we humans are
doing Wildlife trade industrial scale
animal farms and my focus
today clearing of tropical
forests changes in the way land is used
particularly deforestation may be the
single biggest driver of new animal born
diseases there are three key ways that
deforestation leads to
disease first the animals that survive
deforestation such as some types of bats
tend to be ones that can live alongside
people for whatever the reason these
animals often carry germs that can
infect
us second when people move into
deforested areas they come into closer
contact with Wildlife creating
opportunities to pass asrs back and
forth finally animals are more likely to
spread disease when they're stressed
from losing their
homes to make matters worse the threat
of infectious disease is only growing as
our planet
warms over half of known infectious
diseases in humans have been aggravated
by climate change at some point the
World Health Organization even considers
climate change the greatest threat to
human health we face today now I know
what some of you are thinking would
anybody really miss these guys if we
kill the bats wouldn't that solve our
problem of course not and I'm not just
saying that because bats are my second
favorite group of animals after
snakes if anything we just get exposed
to more viruses when killing them we
also depend upon bats for pollination
and insect
control but there is something we can do
right now that would have an immediate
impact on health and climate what's more
it'll cost way less Le than fighting the
next
pandemic so what is this
solution protecting tropical
forests people don't clearcut Forest
because it's fun work corporations may
do it to make money in global
markets rainforest communities many of
which are very poor may do it too just
to
survive understanding these Dynamics
gives us a road map to reverse
it in the early 2000s for example
Brazilian government officials monitored
Forest loss with satellites and cracked
down on illegal
deforestation they returned territory to
indigenous peoples who have successfully
managed the Amazon for thousands of
years under public pressure businesses
sto selling beef and soy from Recently
deforested
lands these efforts paid off from 2004
to
2012 deforestation in the Amazon
plummeted by over
80% even better agricultural output
increased dispelling the myth that
there's a trade-off between forest and
food but here's the tricky thing about
deforestation it's
hyperlocal there's no one siiz fits-all
solution that means above all else we
need to
listen that may sound a little fluffy
but bear with
me in Indonesian Borneo a nonprofit
called health and Harmony conducted what
it calls radical listening to arrive at
Community design solutions to
deforestation communities concluded that
deforestation could be reversed if they
had quality healthare and better
jobs so the nonprofit along with local
Partners built a
clinic they trained community members to
farm
organically they invested in youth
education lo and behold the communities
were
right over the next decade deforestation
dropped meanwhile Health improved infant
mortality decreased by
2third what we see here is that people
and Planet don't need to be in
Conflict we have solutions to address
deforestation and if we Implement them
wisely we can prevent outbreaks and slow
climate change preventing outbreaks by
Saving nature will also help ensure that
income doesn't dictate outcome the tools
we use to respond to outbreaks
medicines
vaccines even information are
inequitably
distributed in contrast prevention
benefits everyone
equally so how can we accelerate uptake
of preventative solutions to
outbreaks by Building Bridges between
the health climate and conservation
sectors pandemics climate change and
environmental destruction feed off each
other but like the health sector the
climate sector hasn't fully recognized
the value of nature nature focused
projects for example can get us over 30%
of the emissions reductions needed to
reach our climate goals but only receive
about 5% of climate
funding in my own work I was also
conditioned to overlook
nature for years I was made to feel
guilty for caring about species other
than
humans like it was a betrayal of the
oath I took when I became a doctor right
after I finished my training I met a
well-renowned physician and scientist
who I had looked up to for years I was
excited to ask him for his thoughts on
how to improve human well-being while
safeguarding the
planet he looked at me and slowly
said I don't care about polar
bears at first I was
shocked and then I felt
embarrassed but from what I've seen from
fighting outbreaks for over a decade I'm
finally comfortable admitting that I do
care about polar
bears and
bats and
forests and
people we all need
to because there is no human health or
animal health or environmental health
they one and the
same in West Africa it may have taken
just one infected animal to spark an
ebola epidemic that killed more than
11,000
people but it will take everyone to
sustain the delicate ecological balance
that we all depend upon thank
you